[Applause]
in jurassic park's famous kitchen scene
this shot featured a man in a full
raptor suit
while the raptors in this shot were
created digitally
these shots featured raptor puppets and
actors wearing raptor boots and gloves
you know that great moment where the
raptor reached in opens the door
that's just a guy wearing a raptor glove
and reaching around the jurassic movies
have constantly innovated how dinosaurs
appear on screen pushing cgi forward
while never exclusively relying on
digital methods even in 2022
we spoke with nine of the minds behind
the jurassic creatures to find out how
dinosaur effects have evolved over the
course of three decades
steven spielberg first envisioned his
dinosaurs as entirely stop-motion
creations designed by legendary
stop-motion animator phil tippett how'd
you do this
i'll show you
they didn't want to initially trust that
we could do full cg
t-rex's because he was the most
important critter in there all the other
ones could kind of wander around in the
background but as far as the actors
acting to that that was the big one
until we got the test shot
that we showed the stephen and that's
what changed the film gene was there for
one of these initial tests suddenly you
went from things that were are you like
a skeleton or or the mercury man in c2
you went to something that had color and
texture and sheen to it you could put
anything anywhere on the screen and make
it alive
the only problem it looked like the
manpower needed on the computer
animation side would be too high
so the stop-motion artists at tipit
studios worked with the vfx team at ilm
to develop dinosaur input devices or
dids physical models of the dinosaurs
hooked up to computers the skeletons
were covered with sensors that tracked
the orientations of their joints and
sent that information to the computer
translating the movement into keyframes
traditional stop-motion animators could
then work with the computer models
without having to master computer
animation software shifting their skills
to the digital realm that was the thing
that really melted the glacial divide
between traditional stop-motion and
computer graphics
thanks to cg jurassic park's t-rex could
go from being a background character to
a star of the film spielberg even
rewrote the ending to include this fight
between the cgt rex and two raptors
the real secret to the dinosaurs
believability though when we first meet
the t-rex in the paddock sequence it is
a combination of cg and practical
effects designed by fx pioneer stan
winston and his team of sculptors
puppeteers and mechanics
that sequence cuts between both
methodologies if you intercut cg with an
actual physical onset puppet they're
never quite sure what they're looking at
that is the reason that that remains to
this day one of the more realistic
fantasy moments in cinema history the
animatronic dinosaurs had their own
advancements the dinosaurs of jurassic
park required a whole rethink on the
mold making process traditionally in
practical effects it would be done with
various types of stones but these would
not be appropriate materials for
gigantic molds so the studio looked to
the epoxies that were being used in the
aerospace industry and applied those
materials for the dinosaurs it allowed
them to create very large very durable
molds that would retain their integrity
they wouldn't warp like these raptor
puppets seen in the attack on muldoon i
was actually the raptor left arm
puppeteer in most sequences the arm
cable actuated devices allowed for
fantastic expressiveness with their
hands and for the iconic complex kitchen
sequence that sequence involves every
possible trick in the book to make you
believe raptors are real cgi raptors
insert puppets that were basically the
head and a bit of the neck lower body
rigs that were just the legs raptor
gloves it includes men in raptor suits
when they first enter the kitchen and
one of them rears up and hoots
that's a man in a suit the men in suit
approach was great for wider shots like
that but when you're close up more often
than not it will be a puppet ultimately
there were 15 minutes of dinosaurs in
jurassic park nine minutes are practical
puppets six minutes are cgi stan was a
huge believer that the best way to fool
an audience is don't lean too heavily on
one technique keep them guessing
by the time the second jurassic movie
rolled around practical innovations
meant the team could lean even more on
animatronics on jp2 they changed it up
they wanted the skins to move more
realistically and so they created an
elaborate network of foam musculature
and on top of those foam muscles that
moved and intersected very realistically
they laid a much thinner skin so that
you could actually get a sense of the
musculature moving underneath the skin
plus stan winston's mechanics extended
their use of hydraulic motors used on
the t-rex in the first movie even though
the tyrannosaurus rex from jurassic park
one was by far the toughest character to
pull off it actually was the easiest to
puppeteer because it was a hydraulic
puppet puppeteered via a telemetry
device where it only took a few people
to puppeteer that big t-rex so that
technique was what we used for every
dinosaur in jurassic park too other than
the smallest of them and thanks to that
approach the raptors which in the first
one took 18 of us at times to operate
only took two or three people to operate
in jurassic park ii the smallest
dinosaurs still relied on more
traditional puppetry like the
comsignathus or compies chicken-sized
dinosaurs that attack in packs most
notably when they team up to kill the
hunter
there were so many of them and so many
cg ones had to jump on this actor and
they all had to be performing and the
guy's moving like this and thrashing and
he's pulling him with all the weights
when they jump onto this moving guy had
to be right stan winston's team built
several types of puppets to perform a
range of compy behaviors one type of
puppet attached to the actor via velcro
pads on a hidden suit super strong
fishing line raked the puppet up to an
off-screen controller which a puppeteer
could tug on to create a pecking motion
meanwhile an airline trigger ran air
through the compy's tail causing it to
whip around in a frenzy for this shot of
storm mayor trying to grab and pull the
compies off the team used a puppet with
high-powered magnets on its feet these
magnets attach to other magnets sewn
into the actor's clothes making the
combi difficult to pull off the
puppeteers could also be as close to the
puppets as needed since they could just
be erased in post the
length of the puppeteering rods before
digital had to be really long if you
can't get close to the puppets you can't
really do much in terms of controlling
it it's always going to have this kind
of bouncing kind of floaty kind of
quality now with digital you can choke
up on that rod you can be just a couple
inches from the puppet and you can be
moving it around really smoothly the
prime example is the sequence where the
little girl and the compy interact there
on the beach the puppeteers were right
there they were within just a foot or
two of that copy in the final shots the
team mixed puppet copies with digital
ones which you can spot based on
movement mainly the ones that seem to
have a lot of a lot of pizzazz and a lot
of anger i think are the ones that we
could animate enough to make them look
interesting these mini dinosaurs set the
stage for a much larger creature in
jurassic 3 which would demand the
heaviest biggest and fastest dinosaur
robot ever built
we wanted a dinosaur that could defeat
t-rex you know t-rex is everybody's
favorite dinosaur the movie's
paleontology consultant jack horner
suggested the spinosaurus which was
bigger and more vicious capable of
killing the t-rex in the final showdown
the foundation of that final showdown
was practical filmed with two massive
animatronics as demonstrated here in an
early hand puppet test
but filmmakers couldn't have the two
puppets really go at it they would have
destroyed each other pretty quickly so
they storyboarded a fight that used an
animatronic spinosaurus and a digital
t-rex in some shots and vice versa in
others that i think was the first time
in jurassic park movies that they were
actually interacting with each other
physically for the animatronics the crew
took one of the t-rexes from the
previous movie out of storage and
refurbished it for the fight but the
spinosaurus had to be built from scratch
the audience had to believe that this
dinosaur could kill a t-rex so it had to
be bigger it had to be faster the t-rex
had about 200 horsepower driving it the
spinosaurus had a thousand horsepower it
was five times more powerful it was far
sturdier than the t-rex as well which
had actually been quite delicate once
the final spinosaurus design got a
thumbs up from a consulting
paleontologist the team sculpted an
eight foot long one-fifth scale maquette
instead of sculpting the animatronic
from clay like they did for the t-rex
the crew went with a more high-tech
method they used a cyber scan of the
maquette to create computer milled foam
pieces
and all these pieces had to withstand a
very specific element
water
jurassic park one the t-rex was rained
upon extensively the foam skins acted
like a sponge and absorbed tons of water
in every shot which affected its
performance because it was finely tuned
to a certain weight but when all the
water was absorbed it changed all those
calculations they waterproofed the
t-rexes in jurassic park 2 with a layer
of silicone over the foam skin and that
waterproofing approach reached its
pinnacle with the spinosaurus
which the inner mechanical devices were
waterproof in waterproof housings
aspects of the spinosaurus's face were
actually cast in a solid urethane that
would not absorb water that to this day
remains the guinness book of world
records largest animatronic ever built
for a film it was so large it had to be
lifted with cranes and driven to
universal studios on a route that didn't
go under bridges
once on set the crew mounted it to a
motorized cart that ran on tracks which
allowed the animatronic to move forward
and backward while it moved up and down
on cylinders
and to get those fast movements you see
here the spinosaurus used
state-of-the-art hot rod hydraulics
controlled by an 18-inch telemetry
device william h macy who played paul
kirby in the film said the puppet could
turn its head at twice the force of
gravity with the tip of its nose moving
at a hundred miles per hour
its strength didn't make it
indestructible though that scene with
the airplane every take it would lose
one of its claws every take was a all
right go back to the shop when filming
the big fight the two teams of
puppeteers used their telemetry devices
to swing the puppets around it took
about 12 animatronic operators to do
each one of them although they tried to
keep physical contact between the two
puppets to a minimum the t-rex still got
hurt it was actually before the fight
started it was the two animatronic
dinosaurs were roaring at each other
t-rex sort of started going crazy the
puppet was just sort of vibrating and it
turns out that one of the hydraulic
lines had broken inside and hydraulic
fluid was going everywhere and
re-skinned part of it and tried to sew
it back together and everything it was
wild it's on film somewhere 14 years
later major improvements in performance
capture made complex movement like this
possible in the second jurassic
franchise a step up from puppets and
stop motion jurassic world sought to
bring its velociraptors to a whole new
level of realism giving them an
unprecedented complexity of motion
it was difficult for a performance
capture artist to physically stand the
way that a raptor's supposed to for a
prolonged period of time and
velociraptors do have a unique size and
shape compared to human performers but
ilm was able to retarget the captured
performances of the human actors to the
raptor bodies without losing the
subtlety of the performances
the reward was that the raptors look
heavy and lifelike with very intricate
movement on screen
with cg having advanced to this level
the next film could go beyond pure
realism to give life to a genetically
engineered dinosaur that never actually
existed
the indoraptor
unsurprisingly this massive dinosaur
would mainly be a digital creation but
the actors needed something to react to
on set there was a lot of physical
interaction between the actors and the
dinosaurs in fallen kingdom more so
maybe than in the previous films
the solution for some scenes came in the
form of partial animatronics like this
giant mechanical arm and a moving
breathing head operated by a team of
puppeteers who controlled the tiny
movements in the eyes a good deal of the
indoraptor was performed using a
real-time animatronic the crew also
built a non-moving head we created a
full-size indoraptor head and neck and
tail that was made from a very
lightweight inflatable material so we
actually blew it up like a child's
bouncy castle made a rig for it to allow
two performers to wear one the front end
and on the back end we would use these
inflatable versions in any scene where
the actors needed an eye line or visual
effects needed a scale representation
that wouldn't be in the frame these
various forms of the indoraptor not only
provided the cast with tangible scene
partners they also gave the camera team
something physical to work with and the
vfx team a reference for the indo's
lighting and movement the movement of
the indo-rapture seemed to me to be
quite faithfully followed i'm never
really quite sure whether there was a
paint overlay or whether or not there
was a complete sea substitution for the
indoor actually in the end i find very
difficult to know where and when the
technique begins it's great
on jurassic world dominion decades of
innovation made it possible to create
hybrid dinosaurs that were part cg part
puppet like the giganotosaurus a
dinosaur with a head the size of a car
the head roughly just sort of just above
the shoulders was an animatronic and the
rest of the creature is digital and if
you can see where it's slightly slightly
more opaque white around the head and
the neck that's the physical piece of
the dinosaur that was going to be made
as an animatronic we needed to be able
to keep it and extend the rest of the
dinosaur in post-production and so it
was really important that it moved in
the same way as our digital creature so
this is the range of motion in the
physical animatronic sufficient to allow
the dinosaur to do what it needs to do
we could actually pass that information
back to john nolan who was the creature
effect supervisor so when john was
making the animatronics they would be
positioned in such a way that matched
iln digital models so it's kind of
digital creatures driving practical
animation
to reflect paleontological research the
digital team also developed tools to
create feathered dinosaurs feathers has
been a long burning desire i think for
all of the jurassic fans and there's a
really complicated to simulate and to
describe all of that very intricate
geometry in 3d so we actually built a
brand new feather system at ilm in
houdini that we dubbed internally quill
so we were able to build this procedural
system which gave the artist the control
over the groom and the texturing of
those feathers it allowed simulation
with snow wind water all in the same
software package even with new feathered
creatures the dinosaurs created by stan
winston and ilm nearly three decades ago
are still seen in today's movies for
jurassic world dominion director colin
trevorrow wanted the vfx creatures to
feel as close as possible to its
predecessors so the digital team
conducted what they called digital
archaeology the t-rex is where this
digital archaeology comes in we actually
went back into the island of digital
archives from the original jurassic park
and we restored the original 3d
softimage models so we were able to make
sure that the model we're using for
dresser work dominion matched as closely
as possible and at the same time we
actually went back to stan winston's
original physical animatronic we have
loads of really amazing reference
photography of it and we completely
retextured the t-rex to match it cg has
come a long way since then ilm only had
60 shots in jurassic now we'll do
several thousand shots in a movie we are
aware that these walks the face of the
earth and for that they have a very very
special place and it also makes it that
much more exciting because you're kind
of you know wow i'm bringing something
to light a real thing to life
[Music]